when you and David Lee Ross toured
together and as I understand as I
understood the Sammy Davis tour and as I
understood it every night you would flip
a coin to see who was going to open and
who was going to close no we just did
that the first night to see who opened
the first show then after that we
flip-flopped flip-flop got it okay so
and it was the first show was the one in
in Los Angeles no the first show was in
Cleveland Ohio and and Dave won he got
to close Okay but then in La was that on
a flip yeah and see in La it was I my
turn so Dave insisted that we do two
nights in La so we did we could sell out
anywhere it was fine you know right but
you know because he had to have well he
was trying to fight for well why I need
that town and I'm going to the same
negotiation [__] you shouldn't
be opening any I mean you shouldn't be
closing the show anyway be honest with
you at that time he didn't have a solo
career really I mean he did but he
wasn't like selling I was selling out
Arenas I was selling amphitheaters in
San Diego you know with the wabos uh and
he you know I had a solo career so let
me just say this he has to make Jagger
ask Robert Plant you can be the biggest
band in the world and you can't
necessarily have a solo career but I had
a solo career so when I joined the big
band I went back to my solo career I'm
good I still sell a lot of tickets you
know Dave
yeah he had that little you know sort of
a big album one kind of a big album but
he didn't have a solo career you know he
was playing small places and you know he
would and so when he came in with me he
was making like 25 Grand and I I was
making 150 a night and they said oh you
guys going to make the same money Dave
gets to make 150. I said he ain't
[__] made 150 in his life in the
center of Van Halen so but then I but I
said I gotta do this I gotta do this so
I did I bent over backwards and he still
always tried to [__] with the with the
rules did you do you're not a fun guy
he's that nice he doesn't play well with
others I'm not sure what his problem is
did you do the two nights in La yeah and
then did you so you each got to close
one night exactly okay and then you know
he he just always is about how can I you
know
make this guy look bad or not just me in
life I mean how can I make myself
he's a chest beating [__] man
and you know God bless him because like
I said that early stuff is freaking
great I yeah sure I but I I personally
I've tried to say you know he'd be a
funny guy to know but he ain't like that
he ain't like his Persona when you get
around him he ain't that guy man he's
some other cat
when you describe what he does on stage
as Vaudeville do you like uh like with
the the acrobatics and the jumping and
the dancing like
Hey listen I'm a showman too but he's
that's his gig he doesn't care about
singing if he did he'd take care of his
voice or he'd take voice lessons he'd
warm up he'd do something because the
guy sings so bad last time he was doing
shows it was embarrassing to me when
people say oh you were in Van Halen I'm
going no no no
deny it just in case they thought I was
him uh so now I see what you mean yeah
but he he's a shaman he just everything
show show show and he doesn't care about
his voice which drives me nuts man I
care more about my voice than I do my
dick
wow
didn't work a couple times I'd be okay
with it but you know I'd be bummed out
but if my voice [__] up on stage I'm
[__] bummed yeah
um
well I'm not sure if that's a fact but
you know
as a metaphor you know what I'm saying
when you're on the Sam and Dave tour
yeah you each have your own bands is
that how it worked yeah he had a Van
Halen tribute band he just said this is
Van Halen the guitar player did Eddie
solo the drummer did as and the bass
player even played Mikey's bass solo and
he acted like it was a Van Halen show
and it was really the wrong thing he got
ripped apart by the press for it because
you know he didn't
should have went out and presented
himself as David Lee Roth with you know
it's Van Halen's staff and his solo said
he didn't play one [__] solo thing
you know he had some good solo songs
last year you did the Sam and Dave show
at the universal Amphitheater that was
small see the reason we did that because
Dave because it was my turn to thank
Dave's insisted upon doing two two
nights so they put us in a smaller place
normally we would have played a bigger
thing yeah you know Dave was he was a
piece of work
really something huh
um when uh if he was sitting here right
now we'd be going
the dude would be tripping he'd be like
oh is that right Sam
he'd call me Sam I don't mind being
called Sam it's just his attitude he
won't look at you and [__] he'll talk to
other people about you yeah
he's a trip man I actually like the guy
he entertains the [__] out of me okay I
mean I think he's an entertaining guy I
I think have you had him on your show no
oh well
I'd be open to it and um I think I would
tell him that uh while his flamboyance
his his uh on stage Antics and
acrobatics and everything is just so
fantastic that between David Lee Roth
and Sammy Hagar I gotta believe Sammy
Hagar is a happier person he'd get up
and walk
do you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butt hole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
plus Stephen's butthole destroyer and
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right now
yeah I do